social media CEOs head to Capitol Hill
and promise censorship to their
political overlords we will analyze the
sniveling testimony then Alex Jones
shirtless vitamin salesman actually
makes a good point
scientists extol the health benefits of
friending God and Pope Francis tells his
critics to shut up
in today's this is America segment Cosby
Show actor Jeffrey Owens explains the
value of work finally on this day in
history the first session of the
Continental Congress convenes without
Kamala Harris shrieking even one time we
will analyze the unpleasant reason for
our governments dysfunction spoiler
alert it is not in Our Stars but in
ourselves sad I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
I set through all of that testimony just
for you I listen to Jack Dorsey spout
sniveling little line after line just
for you the Cavanaugh hearing all of it
what I do for you what I do for you
people because I love you so much before
we get to all of that awful testimony
and so much more today we have got to
thank sip recruiter see I'm about to do
even more for you
zip recruiter you know about zip
recruiter it is the best job place on
the internet sends your job to over 100
of the web's leading job boards they
don't just stop there with their
powerful matching technology a zip
recruiter scans thousands of resumes to
find people with the right experience
and invite them to apply to your job
time is money
zip recruiter is the single best tool to
use because when you post to a job board
yet it's just kind of like throwing
spaghetti at the wall it's like throwing
it up into the air when super cruder
does is it will actually go out and
match with candidates it's so effective
that 80% of employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within the first day so
we'll go out there to find the top
candidates for you you will not miss a
candidate with results like that it's no
wonder that zip recruiter is the highest
rated hiring site in America right now
my listeners can try zip recruiter for
free don't say I never did nothing for
you at this exclusive web address write
it down if you're driving pull over and
get a pen out right now or a phone or
something
zip recruiter comm slash MKS that zip
recruiter comm /m k s zip recruiter comm
/ MKS zip recruiter the smartest way to
hire the smartest way to hire now we're
gonna go from the smartest way to hire
to one of the stupidest ways that we
hire people which is voting them into
Congress and then having them call these
tech CEOs and having them blather on and
on about we have to censor people this
was really frustrating I actually have
some pity for Jack Dorsey here I think
Jack Dorsey he's not a crazed leftist
he's not really an activist he seems to
have the entire world angry with him
right now at first it looked like Jack
Dorsey of Twitter was going to resist
calls for censorship he was saying no
we're not going to censor Alex Jones no
we're not going to censor this guy
a sense of that guy and then he caved he
totally caved without any explanation
and that there's shadow banning going on
at that company we know their shadow
banning there are actually reports that
before this testimony suddenly magically
all of those shadow bans were lifted as
their services were you can check it so
they're aware of this this bias runs
deep Jack Dorsey admitted that his
company has a left-wing bias when he was
talking to brian Stelter a couple weeks
ago on CNN I know that nobody watches
CNN but I watch it for you so that I can
explain the suit
these insightful moments like when Jack
Dorsey admits his own bias but I want to
take you through his testimony line by
line Muse it's he sounds almost as
though he's serious and unbiased and
willing to take action and what you when
you actually parse the wording you
realize it's exactly the opposite so
here's Jack Dorsey in any public space
you'll find inspired ideas and you'll
find lies and deception people who want
to help others in unify and people who
want to hurt others and themselves and
divide what separates a physical and
digital public space is greater
accessibility and velocity we're
extremely proud of hoping to increase
the accessibility and velocity of a
simple free and open exchange we believe
people will learn faster by being
exposed to a wide range of opinions and
ideas and it helps them make our nation
and the world feel a little bit smaller
now listen to those words because this
all sounds great doesn't simple free
open exchange of ideas that's what all
of these tech companies are saying they
are we are an open platform
we're not publishers we're not activists
we're not a campaign organization this
is a very important distinction because
if the tech companies are publishers
then they're gonna be liable for all of
the copyright violations that are
uploaded to them they're gonna be liable
for some of their campaign work if
they're seen to be punishing certain
candidates helping out other candidates
that could be an in-kind donation that
can lead to campaign finance questions
so he's very very clear he says this is
about an open simple exchange of ideas
just like we have the public square
we also have the digital public swear
and that is what Twitter is and by the
way for anyone who's ever visited public
squares crazy people go to public
squares and shout out a bunch of
nonsense that's fine that that's what
happens that's called the free and open
exchange of ideas so that's how he sets
us up all sounds great Jack tell us more
we are proud of how that free and open
exchange has been weaponized and used to
distract and divide people and our
nation we found ourselves unprepared and
ill-equipped for the immensity of the
problems that we've acknowledged what
excuse me
you'll notice that word weaponized this
is the the line that the left uses a lot
now when they say they say I really like
free speech but and then they negate
everything that came before the but they
used the word weaponized but if free
speech is a good thing then weaponizing
free speech is also a good thing right
if it's great doesn't weaponizing well
how do you weaponize a good thing to
weaponize the right is to is to use it
against your adversaries and against
your opponents but that's the purpose of
free speech that's not perverting the
nature of free speech that's not
distorting it that's actually using free
speech for its intended purpose the
whole reason that we have a public
square is so that we can exchange ideas
that we disagree with he says we want
the open simple exchange of ideas well
if you're exchanging ideas presumably
though that exchange is not going to be
of ideas that are exactly the same
then you're not exchanging anything
there's no trade going on at all you're
just a chorus but when you have an
exchange then you are using language
you're using words to convey ideas that
oppose other people's ideas now you can
call that weaponizing them but that's
the exact purpose of free speech all of
politics politics comes down in its most
essential core to meaningful speech to
people who use speech to convince their
other countrymen or their citizens or
whatever of one policy or another policy
to influence them in one way or the
other to persuade them to convince them
that one course of action is better than
another course of action to call it
weaponizing is just to say I really
support free speech but I
when free speech is used as free speech
that's what he's saying go on Jack abuse
harassment troll armies propaganda
through BOTS and human coordination
misinformation campaigns
and divisive filter bubbles that's not a
healthy public square' worse a
relatively small number of bad faith
actors were able to game twitter to have
an outsize impact okay so let's just use
the word propaganda to begin he says
propaganda is infiltrating the public
square propaganda is the essence of the
public square propaganda is is making an
argument for just one side of the of a
dispute so if you say well FoxNews is
propaganda FoxNews is not not their news
programming but they're their commentary
programming that's propaganda for a
conservative point of view sure some of
it might be but MSNBC is propaganda for
a left-wing point of view I don't I
don't say that Rachel Maddow can't have
her free speech I mean what would happen
to my show I said Rachel Maddow isn't
entitled to her free speech button
likewise I don't say Sean Hannity isn't
entitled to his is it prop acquit is
propaganda propaganda is is a one-sided
argument it's a one-sided point of view
of a political issue so that exists
there I also love that he says that
people and robots and robots under human
control are infiltrating the public
square what are those robots that aren't
under human control well what are those
guys doing there I actually do think
that we should maybe attack them
we need to weaponize weapons against the
robots or who have broken free and are
attacking us but as for the robots that
are being controlled by humans and by
that we just mean humans who are using
technology to convince people of their
own political goals which is what we're
all doing when we use computers or cell
phones or this show or anything that
isn't that isn't some nefarious turn of
events or innovation that is what these
platforms were built for so again he's
just constantly using he says I love
free speech but I hate what free speech
is used for and I hate when it is used
and how it is used and through what
media it is used go on Jack we're now
removing over 200 percent more
for violating our policies we're
identifying and challenging 8 to 10
million suspicious accounts every week
and we're thwarting over a half million
accounts from logging in to Twitter
every single day we've learned from 2016
and more recently from other nations
elections how to protect the integrity
of Elections better tools stronger
policy and new partnerships are already
in place
what integrity of Elections what
integrity of Elections is being
threatened here is Twitter being used to
go in and change voting machines is
Twitter going being used to go in and
disrupt buses and stop people from
getting to the polls as that no of
course not what Twitter is the public
square it's not the voting machine it's
not the election it's not the ballot
counter it's not the car that takes you
to the polls it's a public square so
when we're talking about interfering in
elections what you're really talking
about as you've been talking the whole
time is political speech you're saying
now people are using Twitter for
political speech that's the whole
purpose of it I thought free speech was
the whole point the open exchange of
ideas in a public forum so yes they are
they are doing that listen to how he
says he's fixing this he's saying that
his answer his way to fix the problems
with Twitter which are censorship and
shadow banning and treating
conservatives unfairly and artificially
boosting left-wing views the way he's
combating that is banning 200 percent
more people is questioning 8 to 10
million accounts is regularly preventing
half a million accounts from logging on
he's saying our way because it's
supposed to be an open public square for
the extry extry Vai Diaz and something
has gone wrong in that so the way we're
gonna make it open and free and keep
exchanging ideas is booting off millions
and millions of people and harassing
them and making it harder to use the
service that's his set of solutions
that's what he thinks
is going to help is there any more jack
do you have anything more to say oh
that's all well I have to have done it
it goes on and on and on I I guess we
can cut it there because it's it's more
of the same it's all more of the same
he's totally wrong here when I was
watching this testimony
it was so clear that the the problem
with Twitter is not that conservatives
have points of view it's not that
foreign people are on Twitter it's an
international platform it's not only
Americans there you can't say that we're
colluding with other people other
nations whatever people are open able to
have an open exchange of ideas it's not
that there's too much of that the the
main problem with Twitter is censorship
and I'll explain how that we can fix
that just one second before I do that
though while I was watching Jack Dorsey
this morning sitting in my bathrobe so
frustrated at my kitchen table the only
thing I was able to calm me down made me
feel better
was my delicious black rifle coffee and
the black rifle Coffee goes very well by
the way in the leftist here's tumbler I
know usually I try to use it just for
leftist tears but they're so salty these
days that it gets corroded after a while
and you've got to wash it out with
something really nice and good and
wholesome like black rifle coffee you've
tried it before if you haven't you must
it is superb coffee first and foremost
that is the most important thing because
I eat no matter how much I love what a
company does and I love what black rifle
coffee does they support veteran
organizations they support first
responders they they deliver coffee
right to your door so you don't have to
worry about you know going to the store
or this or that but the most important
thing I don't really care about that as
much as whether the coffee is excellent
this coffee is superb you will not get a
better cup of coffee out here it is so
so good they have a coffee club makes it
easy no lines no running out they also
obviously give a portion of their sales
to veterans and first responder causes
go to black rifle coffee calm slash go
FFA COV fe f e receive 15% of your first
order don't say I never did nothing for
you black rifle coffee calm / co' FFA co
v fe fe coffee coffe ethic coffee cafe
black rifle coffee calm / coffe FA Co V
Fe Fe get 15% off the the solution here
is all there's the 200 million you're
kicking off of Twitter the the 10
million or the two hundred percent more
that you're kicking off the the eight to
ten million that you're regularly
questioning the half a million that
you're preventing from logging on that's
the problem the solution that he
proposes is the problem transparency is
another problem but that is the problem
I was there I was recently rereading a
ese or a speech s posed by John Milton
he's the guy who wrote Paradise Lost
and it's called the Areopagitica and
it's it is one of the greatest defenses
of free speech ever
he gave it he gave it before Parliament
and it is this resounding defense of
free speech I'm seriously considering
posting all 19,000 or 20,000 words of
the Areopagitica to Twitter tweet by
tweet because there is a total
misunderstanding lack of appreciation of
the free exchange of ideas in free
speech and what makes this testimony so
Orwellian is the whole introduction is
how this we want Twitter to be a free
open platform a free open platform bs
pal clearly not because all the rest of
your testimony and negated that the
reason they're so insistent on this is
because they don't want to get regulated
like publishers they don't want to get
regulated like political actors they
want to get regulated out of business
but you've got to live up to what your
to what your platform is supposed to be
what was founded to be because
coincidentally while all of this was
happening we witnessed the biggest
one-day drop in tech stocks in months it
dragged the Nasdaq down it hit Twitter
especially hard a Twitter was down 5.2
percent
Google's down 1.7% at the highest I
think they've rebounded a little by now
and by the way I'm not saying that this
is caused by the testimony we're not
even sure if the testimony has priced
into this yet but certainly it is the
case that all of the scandals that have
plagued big tech in recent months all of
which by the way are related to how
freely information is exchanged the
privacy issues the censorship issues the
shadow bending all of that creates
uncertainty in tech stocks because the
the tech stocks are not doing what
they're supposed to do either Twitter is
going to be an open platform and it's
going to be Twitter or there won't be
Twitter it's not going to be something
else the left always goes in and
perverts these institutions either
either Twitter will do what it does or
where there won't be a Twitter it will
just disappear and we know this by the
way to look at the decline in users so a
new study came out from Pew Research 42%
of Facebook users have taken a break
from the platform in the past year
42% that is a shocking amount
I mean I use it all the time obviously
we broadcast on these platforms these
platforms have given conservatives such
an opportunity that's why the left is so
angry why the left is pressuring them to
censor all of us because it gets given a
such an opportunity to get our views out
unvarnished to the American people you
know for decades and decades and decades
the mainstream media had this awful
monopoly they controlled the point of
view a conservative could never get his
point of view add to the people it would
only be seen through a perverted and
distorted narrative lens of the
mainstream media we crashed that because
of social media now they're trying to
take it back that's why they're so
furious this is why Trump has got to
keep tweeting I know there's the
conservative sent the sort of
conservative aristocratic own Oh
pish-posh you shouldn't tweet take the
phone away no the phone's the whole
thing I'm here for the phone keep
tweeting tweeting is the way that we're
able to get our message out unvarnished
in the case of President Trump it's very
unvarnished it's very it's not or not
really polished up at all but that's
fine yours you're getting their point of
view across in the last year 54% of
Facebook users have adjusted their
privacy settings over 1/4 of Facebook
users in the past year a quarter 26%
have deleted the app from their phone
and Facebook's a mobile platform now
people use it on mobile much more than
they use it on desktop 26% have deleted
the app from their phone that is a
shocking number and it gets even more
shocking because it's specifically among
young people who've done that number
when you look at just 18 to 29 year old
Facebook users 44% have deleted the app
from their phone that is a terrifying
number for Facebook because I think the
number is only 12% if deleted it from
their phone for 65 and over but of that
young group it's so high why is it
because there's no transparency because
these big tech companies have abused
privacy settings they've used data
dishonestly and because they are
censoring half of their audience they're
saying how no you can't nope this isn't
fair when people don't play by the rules
we get very sick of it we tune out it's
all about trust it's all about do we
trust these companies now before I don't
want to harp on this too much because we
could talk about social media all day
I'm sure there's gonna be fallout from
us before we move on I do have to get to
the best part of all
of the hearings mr. Jones take it away
testing here going that's happening here
you say I don't exist
sure and the hearings informing tens of
millions of years the rush limbaugh you
know zoom in for DES they play this joke
over here that's why Ted the D platform
didn't work you're not going to silence
me kinda sounds about you are like you
are literally little gangster thug
threatened to physically take care of me
so there's so much here if you couldn't
hear that that would be mr. Marco Rubio
and Alex Jones comes into this little
press gaggle and she starts getting
right in Rubio's face there's a big
debate happening right now over how
Rubio handled this I got to say I think
he could have handled it better I don't
think this was the best way if Alex
Jones gets up in your face starts
screaming at you you're at a hearing
about the big tech censorship of people
Alex Jones is one of the big faces of
bit of tech censoring people on the
right I use the term of the right
broadly because Alex Jones probably
wouldn't be considered a conservative or
call himself a conservative he's a
little a little more out there than that
but certainly he does fall broadly
within the right there is no way that
Marco Rubio doesn't know who he is
of course Marco Rubio knows who he is
everybody knows who he is he's on TV all
the time
because Alex Jones as you saw in that
clip is very good at making a spectacle
so of course he does I just felt like
this is the kind of classic politician
response a oh I haven't seen that
whenever there's a damaging video or
somebody does a hit piece or does a
damaging advertisement or something they
say oh I haven't seen it I've heard
about
I haven't seen it and they deny and they
deny but that's not credible here and
then the Marco Rubio says I swear to God
I don't know who you are which is I
think for a lot of listeners a little
jarring because we all know that Marco
Rubio knows who Alex Jones is so you say
I swear to God just like Vista this what
are you doing here what is the game that
you're playing and also Alex Jones isn't
gonna take that for an answer and I'll
show you how this ends up too to give
you a recap on Alex media strategy
here's the rest of that what is free
speech there's little frat boys so cool
back to back to you're just so what this
I pity Marco Rubio here because you know
what was he gonna do in this situation
but I think that what he did was just
leave at the end right he said okay I'm
leaving my little press gaggle and you
guys can talk to Alex Jones I'm getting
out of here because it was so awkward it
was not making good video it didn't look
good he should have done that the second
he saw Alex Jones from down the hallway
said like nope not see ya you can't win
an altercation with Alex Jones that's
not gonna happen he know Alex Jones
creates spectacle there is no way to win
that there's no way to look cool doing
that denying that you know who he is
trying to laugh at him trying to get in
his face trying to threaten him whatever
it doesn't work the guy is immune to it
because they're turning the frogs gay
you know I mean it's really so I think
he should have just walked away sooner
if you if you get down into a fight with
Alex Jones you can't leave it looking
good you can't land this is true of a
lot of people in politics but you can't
even looking good when there's a note
when it's a lose lose lose get out of
there he should have done it sooner but
I do have some sympathy for Marco Rubio
but Alex Jones oh what a regardless of
whether they're turning the frogs gay or
any you know conspiracy theories of Alex
Jones's you've got to give the guy
credit cuz he is so compelling on camera
it's so entertaining
we've got more because and by the way
Alex Jones makes a very good point in
the midst of all this chaos but before
we do that I've got to thank Poland
branch the Boland branch sheets you know
I've talked about this I got married
recently this was a nice little wedding
gift to myself I actually bought another
set of these they're so good
bolon branch sheets are like you're
sleeping at the nicest hotel ever you
know that obviously Ben hasn't paid me
for my work here and ever but one of the
perks is when we're traveling I get to
stay at a nice hotel you know if
occasionally they don't put me in the
doghouse sleep and Boeing branch sheets
are like the nicest sheets of the nicest
hotel and you can get them every single
night I didn't realize this you have
expensive sheets really nice sheets can
cost a thousand dollars or more Boland
branch by cutting out the middleman
making their stuff from 100% pure
organic cotton can bring that price down
to just a couple hundred bucks everyone
who tries Boleyn branch loves them
that's why they have thousands of
five-star reviews you are going to love
them three u.s. presidents sleep on them
shipping is free you can try them for 30
nights if you don't love them send them
back but you will not want to send them
back they're great there's no risk no
reason not to give them a try and if you
are a real cheapskate and get a good
night's sleep for 30 nights go to Boleyn
branch calm promo code Michel mi CH AE l
you will get 50 bucks off your first set
of sheets don't say I never did nothing
for you Boland branch calm today for $50
off your first set of sheets Bo ll and
branch calm promo code Michael so in the
midst of all of this in the bath house
comments and bullying whatever you know
Alex Jones is doing he actually made a
good point you made a good point at a
separate moment when he was addressing
the press here here is Alex Jones
actually making a compelling statement
much more compelling than what Jack
Dorsey was saying
I am here because there is a concerted
effort by the Democratic Party and
multinational corporations in big tech
to silence conservative and nationalist
and populist voices ahead of this
critical midterm election and the big
tech companies and the head of Apple
admit that they met with Senator Warner
who's running this whole thing to begin
shutting down conservatives from the
Democrats threatened to federalize big
tech if they did not basically roll over
to him that's a great point he is making
a great point right there which is that
there is a concerted effort by not just
the left in America but the sort of
transnational you know world Federalists
to European Union un kumbaya chorus
crowd which includes multinational
corporations to stamp down voices to
tamp down threads of nationalism of
patriotism of conservatism trying to
tamp those down because it doesn't go
along with the political order that they
think is inevitable that is 100 percent
correct we're gonna be speaking to the
political philosopher Yoram hezonia
about this a little later I think will
air that interview next week but that is
a very good point and he's right about
Mark Warner - they Mark Warner submitted
his proposals for what he was gonna do
did big tech if big tech didn't go
around and start censoring voices that
they that Mark Warner doesn't like and
part of that was we're gonna regulate
you into the ground we're gonna
federalize you we're gonna this that and
the other thing this is actually a
really good point and it makes me go
back and forth on Jones which is if he
if he can make a good point like this in
between talking about the gay frogs like
maybe he should just do that maybe he
should do that instead of just screaming
and mark a ruby his face and creating a
spectacle I don't know I I certainly
prefer the spectacle because it's a lot
more funny and interesting to watch but
this is a really important point and it
does get to the core of our debate over
nationalism today and what the world of
companies are in a country but we'll get
to that a little bit later so all of big
tech is really floundering right now
just look at the stock market and if you
can't look at the stock market look at
the user numbers look at Facebook losing
daily users for the first time ever just
just this year same thing with the
Twitter same thing happened four monthly
users with Twitter one of the solutions
for this is it was a study that just
came out of the University of Michigan
which is that we need to friend God that
was the headline you need to friend God
like your friending him on Facebook but
friend God in real life and I it's a
kind of cheap headline you know it's a
it's a little kitschy or something but I
really do like the point because what
this study found is that religious
people have a stronger sense of
belonging and purpose in life of course
this is true if you live in the modern
materialist knee list worldview that
everything is just a big cosmic accident
it's a tale told by an idiot full of
sound and fury signifying nothing
the only even plausible purpose of life
is to pleasure yourself until you die if
that's your point of view you're not
going to have a sense a purpose because
that worldview precludes the possibility
of a sense of purpose if you believe in
God and particularly the judeo-christian
version of God then you're going to feel
a real sense of purpose if you have
theistic religion you're going to feel
purpose because there is a purpose
there's a teleology this is true even if
you if you were living around an old
uncle Aristotle's day that there was a
purpose to life a purpose to do the good
to pursue virtues which is totally
missing in that materials point of view
so that that makes a lot of sense the
study also found that friendless people
people who don't have a lot of friends
or don't have a big social circle are
more likely to lack direction and
struggle with meaning fair enough
I mean this is true it everybody goes
through this at a certain point of life
they feel a little lonely not all the
time but some of you go through a period
and you sound a little lonely right now
I don't whatever maybe later you got a
big social circle and when you're lonely
when you're isolated when you don't have
a lot of human contact then you can kind
of get lost in your own head and get
lost in what your sense of purpose is in
the world so what the lead author of
this study Todd Chan says is that for
the socially disconnected God may serve
as a substitute relationship that
compensates for some of the purpose the
human relationships would normally
provide this is where it goes totally
wrong because because it is true for
people who who lack substantive social
relationships
you know with human beings God can help
them
God can also help people who do have a
lot of friends in the real world in the
physical world God can help people
who've got some friends and not others
and who have good word friends and this
and that the other thing it isn't a
substitute relationship your
relationship with God is the
foundational relationship so it isn't I
think what the authors of the study are
saying is if you don't have any friends
make an imaginary friend a big guy in
the sky with a beard but that isn't what
God is at all God is the foundation of
those relationships God is the basis of
all meaningful speech God as the basis
of our consciousness and if you've got a
good relationship with God you're gonna
have a better relationship with your
friends if you have a good relationship
with God you're gonna have a better
relationship with your spouse or your
boyfriend or girlfriend that is that is
the route people get this totally
backwards in the world because they
think that the tangible is what is
ultimate the physical is what is
ultimately true but that that isn't the
case this is a very modern idea it's
very mistaken the tangible is a metaphor
for the foundational things which are
metaphysical are our relationships with
our friends are in many ways substitutes
for our relationship with God or there
at least augmentations of that or their
ancillary to them so wish they got that
right but it's very very true I've got
to say goodbye to Facebook and YouTube
we have a lot more to talk about
speaking of God we have to talk about
Pope Francis's new response to his
critics not not terribly polite and it's
two words and they're not happy birthday
they're they're shut up that's what the
words are what were you thinking we also
have to talk we have a great this day in
America and this day or this is America
in this day in history but you watch
Jack Dorsey today you watch you watch
the Cavanaugh hearings yesterday and
today you know what you need I don't
need to tell you if you go to daily
we're calm you'll get me the Andrew
Clayton show the Ben Shapiro show you
get to ask questions in the mailbag
that's coming up tomorrow get them in
you'll get to ask questions in the
conversation yeah blah blah blah blah
blah I don't know I'm not one for mixing
spirits you know beer before liquor
you'll never be sicker liquor before
beer you're all in the clear but do you
put salty leftist tears from Cavanaugh's
hearing before the salty leftist tears
from Jack Dorsey's hearing or do you
have the salty leftist big tech tears
before you have it's very complicated
and you could get
SiC make sure you get this important
tumbler throw some ice cubes in splash
around strain it in a martini glass nice
and chilled throw an olive in there for
good measure you're gonna have a
delicious cocktail go to daily wire
combi we'll be right back with a lot
more
it does sound delish doesn't I'm getting
the shakes already just thinking about
my delicious Kavanagh hearing martini
later yum-yum-yum
so speaking of God Pope Francis is
finally answering some of his critics he
previously said in response to
Archbishop Carlo Maria Vigano
testimony that he was complicit in
covering up some clerical abusive of
seminarians he said I will not say one
word on it
well now Pope Francis is saying more
than one word on it he said quote with
people who lack goodwill with people who
seek only scandal who seek only division
who seek only destruction even within
the family there is nothing to do in
brackets but silence and prayer
may the Lord give us the grace to
discern when we should speak and when we
should stay silent oh my gosh this is
the he was much better when he was
saying I'm not gonna answer my critics
he was this was a that was a much more
satisfying answer than saying shut up I
mean cuz that's what this amounts are
saying shut up that is his answer this
is utterly unacceptable this is a
totally unacceptable answer from the
pontiff and this is really amazing
because from the beginning you've had
people who are not Catholic who are not
Christian in the mainstream media
talking about how wonderful the Francis
pontificate is oh he's so much better
than that old Benedict Benedict ah he I
don't he he was German and we don't like
Germans or whatever they were saying and
now we see a serious incredible charge
of corruption at the highest levels of
the Vatican all the way up to the papacy
we didn't see these charges under Pope
Benedict we now we're seeing this at the
highest levels and what is Pope Francis
saying is that this humble I'm sorry
this is okay I'm gonna answer I'm gonna
no it's shut up that's the answer we're
getting this is totally unacceptable and
people need to be held to account and
I'm telling you the bishops are not
going to get away with this they're not
going to get away with saying oh that's
okay it'll blow over it'll blow over it
won't blow over the Catholic lady in
particular because we're the ones who
donate to the bishops appeal and to all
of the service Catholic Relief
services Catholic Charities everything
connected with the US Conference of
Catholic Bishops which actually in this
case has acted well enough to say there
needs to be an investigation and this
needs to be taken seriously we should
not give a penny not a penny to any of
those things we can give to our churches
don't give to any of those bishops
appeals or any of those bishop charities
until answers are given until heads roll
corrupt prelate s-- get out of here I
mean the Christ's trucks very clearly
about what should happen to those
prelate hsihu cause the least of his
flock to sin and it's that they should
have a it would be better for them if
they had a millstone tied around their
neck and were cast into the bottom of
the sea we should demand accountability
and this answer is just not acceptable
moving on as they'll try to I try to be
measured when I'm talking about these
ecclesial things but it's just
unbelievable the the this is this is a
good way to feel better after after
watching big tech implode after watching
our government implode after watching
the Catholic Church not taking
responsibility for anything this is very
lovely Jeffrey Jones Jeffrey Jones was a
regular character in the latter seasons
of The Cosby Show and he you know he was
always a good actor there and so last
week
some wacko girl took photos of him at
Trader Joe's he was working at a Trader
Joe's and he that she spread it it was
in the Daily Mail it was going all over
the place so they're shaming this guy
for working an honest job this is a
totally honest job working a store is a
great thing he's contributing to his
family I know a lot of actors who don't
work jobs here is Jeffery Owens
explaining his reaction to it I think
this sums up the best of the American
attitude I got to a point where you know
I've been teaching acting directing for
for 30 plus years but you know got to a
point where you know it just it just
didn't add up enough you know and you
got to do what you got to do I I wanted
a job that I could have some flexibility
try to stay in the business
I didn't advertise that I was you know
you know at Trader Joe's only but not
that I was ashamed of it but because I
didn't want the entertainment community
to kind of decide while he's doing that
he's not in you know he's not pursuing
acting anymore you know what oh this
makes perfect sense this might not make
sense to everybody but having worked as
an actor before you know it this does
make sense to me for those of you who
can't see this by the way Jeffery Owens
is wearing his Trader Joe's nametag and
his Yale hat is a Yalie yele by alma
mater and he's wearing both of them at
the same time I love this
there is nothing pretentious about this
guy he's working as actors have to do
he's working a job in between acting
jobs because people who were even
professional and working actors are
almost never actually working a lot of
the time they're just sitting around
waiting or going on auditions or
whatever which doesn't pay a whole lot
even when you book a gig for the vast
majority of actors it does not pay a
whole lot which is why some of us have
to stoop to take jobs at the Daily wire
and write blank books and I'm sorry I
was getting lost in my my own head and
so he did this and there's no shame in
that
I know I know actors I kid you not who
go on the dole who take unemployment
insurance where they take welfare checks
I have heard professional actors
professional actors who have graduated
from Yale refer to the welfare system as
the public arts subsidy no shame no
shame whatsoever about taking their
handout from taxpayers because they want
to do their art which doesn't have much
demand in the marketplace that's not
what Jeffery Owens did Jeffery Owens
this is America baby he said I'm gonna
go out I'm gonna pursue my dream I'm
going to pursue this artistic form that
I'm good at that I've worked at a very
very high level in that I still work at
though at a you know unless publicly
than I did on this big TV show I'm gonna
keep pursuing all of that that crazy
American can-do ambitious artistic dream
and I'm gonna work hard and I'm gonna
put money on the table because I have to
support my family and I have to be a
responsible person this is the best of
America he explains it even more
succinctly I do want to say this I you
know that this business of my being this
Cosby guy who got shamed for working at
Trader Joe's that's going to pass you
know what that that's going to you know
in some measure of time that's going to
pass away but I hope what doesn't pass
is this idea that people are now
thinking this really
thinking about what it means to work you
know the honor of the working person and
the dignity of work and I hope that this
period that we're now where we have a
heightened sensitivity about that and a
reevaluation of what it means to work
and that a revaluation of the idea that
some jobs are better than others because
that's actually not true there is no job
that's better than another job it might
pay better it might have better benefits
it might look better on a resume and on
paper but actually it's not better every
job is worthwhile and and valuable and
if if we have a you know a kind of a
rethinking about that because of what's
happened to me that would be great but
no one should feel sorry for me 100
percent correct that is so correct that
is so clear
he's making his alma mater proud baby I
mean that is so right what a what a
terrifically accurate American idea and
sense of work Adam in the garden was
told to work before the fall work is not
a punishment in the Garden of Eden Adam
was told to work it is in our nature in
the best parts of our nature to work
work is a good thing I see this a lot
with actors I've experienced this actors
get lazy they just kind of loaf around
they wait for the phone to ring and
whatever and it's very depressing when
people are out of work they get
depressed in part it's because the money
isn't coming in in part it's because we
are made to work this is why people who
retire and then don't do anything in
retirement decline very quickly you have
to do something in your retirement you
have to do something with your time and
there is a dignity to work there is no
work that is bad the any job is better
than no job there is no minimum wage the
minimum wage is not $15 an hour or $14
an hour it's zero dollars an hour that's
the true minimum wage that's that's the
minimum wage that you got to get out of
you've got to get some job and there is
what I mean there is work that pays very
well and there is you know as as Jeffery
Owens was saying there's work that pays
far less well but the the actual moral
quality of that work is exactly the same
in some cases the work that pays less
well can be more morally gratifying
perhaps depending on exactly what you're
doing but we're
being productive contributing to society
not being a lout or a lazy guy or a
criminal or do you know people who are
actually contributing that is a an
unqualified good and he's Jeffrey Owens
is embodying that he's articulating it
very well and it's a great thing he's a
real these days when actors and jelly's
are bringing such shame to their
institutions and lines of work in the
country it is so good that one guy who
is both of those things is is making it
is really making that his institutions
proud very good stuff from Jeffrey owns
before we go I know we're running late
tough we're always running late I want
to talk about this day in history this
day in history in 1774 sheds a lot of
light on our present situation as we are
watching the Kavanagh crazy chaotic
hearing the Democrats are turning into a
circus as we're watching the big tech
testimony as we're watching all of this
grandstanding on this day in history in
1774 the First Continental Congress
convened it can be me carpenters Hall in
Philadelphia there were 56 delegates
there Georgia didn't show up but 56
delegates
among those were George Washington John
Adams John Jay Patrick Henry great men
serious men they created the Continental
Association they didn't quite declare
independence
it wasn't time for independence yet it
was in response to the coercive acts the
Intolerable Acts from Britain and this
was a response but it was measured it
wasn't radical it wasn't in you know
some crazy immediately revolutionary
response they they also set a date for
the Second Continental Congress in case
the first one didn't work and Britain
didn't repeal the Intolerable Acts these
were serious men who were going to this
First Continental Congress in a in a way
that really threatened their livelihoods
threatened ultimately would threaten
their lives at the Second Continental
Congress which was to say we are going
to break we're slowly or quickly going
to break away from domination by Great
Britain and they they did this for their
country they did this for their
countrymen for their families for their
states for the colonies at that time
soon-to-be states
for human freedom for higher ideals for
sovereignty and they did what they had
to do in it was a real sacrifice the
early Congress after the Constitution
was ratified the early Congress was paid
six dollars a day
Congress and the Senate they had to move
it out of New York because you can't
live in New York on six dollars a day as
many of them pointed out then what what
has changed from then until now the
early Congress convened for less than
nine months out of the year the first
Congress less than nine months out of
the year they went on long recesses they
didn't want to be in the summer heat now
Congress is in session virtually all of
the time it's never off they're flying
back and forth constantly raising a ton
of money in their districts it is a
totally professionalized job the early
Congress was part-time work and you're
supposed to go and tend to your business
interests at home now Congress has a
full-time job
what has changed how did we get from the
First Continental Congress of Washington
Jay Adams Henry to the Schmucks that are
running around the Capitol right now
creating havoc breaking rules trying to
stop a perfectly admirable Supreme Court
justice nominee how did we get there Ben
Sasse sums this up very well during the
Cavanaugh judiciary hearing here is
Senator Seth because for the last
century and increasing by the decade
right now more and more legislative
authority is delegated to the executive
branch every year both parties do it the
legislature is impotent the legislature
is weak and most people here want their
jobs more than they really want to do
legislative work and so they punt most
of the work to the next branch third
consequence is that this transfer of
power means the people yearn for a place
where politics can actually be done and
when we don't do a lot of big actual
political debating here we transfer it
to the Supreme Court and that's why the
Supreme Court is increasingly a
substitute political battleground in
America it is not healthy but it is what
happens and it's something that our
founders wouldn't be able to make any
sense of and forth and finally we badly
need to restore the proper duties and
the balance of power from our con
to tional system absolutely right a
totally correct diagnosis of what's
happened in the country the the Congress
has given away all of its power to the
executive branch to the executive
agencies to the alphabet-soup CDC FDA
ABC LGBT I don't know I'm losing like
I'm losing my initialisms they've
delegated all of that power away so that
you have the lawmaking being done out of
the executive branch and the reason they
do that is and and by the way in the
case is that it's not made by the
executive the people who demand answers
to their political questions put all of
the pressure on the judiciary which is
why you get absurdly politicized
hearings like the Cavanaugh nomination
the reason that Congress did that is
because Congress has to answer to the
people the president has to answer to
the electors every four years the
judiciary the federal judiciary doesn't
answer they get appointed and they have
life terms and the Congress has to
answer the Senate every six years the
house every two years so the house is
very very close to the people and they
fear that they won't be reelected if
they make laws if they take a stand if
they take any courageous acts they'll be
thrown out of office because the people
won't understand that you have to do
hard things and so they get rid of that
it is easy just to blame Congress as an
institution I'm happy to do it a lot of
the time the Congress is us the Congress
is us we did this the American people
did this the Congress reflects the
American people it is the branch of the
government that that is most closely
related to the people that is supposed
to reflect the political appetites of
the people if there's the logos the
pathos and the ethos the logos the
logical part of the government is
supposed to be the judiciary the ethos
the spirited part of the government is
the executive and the pathos the
appetite the feeling of the government
is supposed to be the Congress the
legislature and our feeling has become
weak and immature and the American
people are given way to base passions
and irresponsibility and recklessness
don't it's so easy we do this all the
time in politics we complain about this
on Twitter this is one of the big
aspects of social media censorship is
they're saying it's to mean people are
being too mean to each other blaming
everyone else for their problems it was
the Russians it was the master
was that this was that no it was you
look at the man in the mirror it is you
before you pluck that little speck out
of your brother's eye pull that big
giant tweet out of your own eye that big
iPhone out of your own eye it is your
fault and you are doing it the way to
improve the country the way to improve
the politics and to improve the public
square and to improve our government is
to improve yourself to be more virtuous
to be better educated to be more curious
to be more civil to be more humble to
have therefore more wisdom that's what
you can do you can
it's not about yelling in people's faces
it's not about blaming this guy or that
guy or that guy you can do that too you
can do I mean these people that Congress
does reflect us so we should hold them
accountable we're but we need to make
sure that we are capable of
self-government and the more and more
that we fall into this cycle of
irresponsibility and blaming and and bad
education and and misinformation the
less able we are going to be to control
that government so take a look at the
man in the mirror huh I I don't know
that I've ever ended a show quoting
Michael Jackson but I didn't think that
was had the show was gonna end today but
take a look at the man in the mirror
come back tomorrow so that we can do the
mail baggage remember questions in in
the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Nolt show I'll see you
tomorrow
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
semia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you
you